THE REPUBLICANS IN CONGRESS
AND CHAIRMAN NUNES.
CONGRESSMAN BIGGS, GOOD TO
HAVE YOU.
>> GOOD TO BE WITH YOU.
DAVID DAVID WHILE THEY TURN
THE LIBERAL AND THE MEDIA
ARE DOING THEIR BEST TO
>> THE KEY WORD IN ALL OF
THERE IS ONLY ONE
INSTITUTION THAT REALLY HAS
BEEN TAINTED THROUGH THESE
MONTHS.
THAT IS THE TRUMP
PRESIDENCY.
>> HAVE YOU GOT HIM
ATTACKING THE JUDICIARY.
HAVE YOU HIM ATTACKING THE
CIA.
YOU HAVE HIM ATTACK THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, THE
FBI.
AND SPEAK OUT AGAINST THEM.
>> THE FBI IS A KEY PART OF
OUR DEMOCRACY.
SO EVERY TIME THE PRESIDENT
TWEETS AGAINST THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, HE IS
MAKING THE RUSSIAN'S JOB A
ELDER.
FORMER PRESS SECRETARY FOR
VICE PRESIDENT PENCE MARK
LOADER AND FOX NEWS LEGAL
ANALYST GREGG JARRETT HERE
WITH ME IN THE STUDIO.
GREGG, I WANT TO GO TO YOU
FIRST AND TAKE OFF OF WHAT
CONGRESSMAN BIGGS SAID.
THE REASON THEY ILLICITTED.
HAVE YOU BEEN VERY CLEAR IN
YOUR WRITINGS ABOUT THE
LAWEN THIS.
AND HOW THIS INVESTIGATION
COUNTER INTELLIGENCE
OPERATION TO FIND FOUGHT
WHAT THE RUSSIANS DID DO YOU
THINK WE ARE GOING TO GET
>> WELL, THE ENTIRE SET OF
INVESTIGATIONS ARE ALL BASED
ON ONE FICTITIOUS DOCUMENT.
INVESTIGATION.
>> David: ADMITTED BY
DIRECTOR COMEY IN THE END.
>> WHICH THEN MORPHED INTO
THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION.
IT WAS ALSO USED APPARENTLY
FOR A FISA WARRANT TO SPY ON
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
SO, IF IT TURNS OUT THAT
YOU IS INHERENTLY A
FRAUDULENT INVESTIGATION.
WHAT STRUCK ME ABOUT WHAT
THE CONGRESSMAN SAID IS
JAMES COMEY'S ROLE IN ALL OF
THIS, HE MAY HAVE COMMITTED
SEVERAL TIMES.
NOT ONLY IN CONVERTING
GOVERNMENT PROPERTY FOR HIS
OWN USE IN LEAKING IT TO
WILL FIND OUT, I GUARANTEE
THIS, THAT JAMES COMEY ALSO
FRIEND AND ALLY AND FORMER
PARTNER ROBERT MUELLER.
WHICH IS UNCONSCIONABLE.
IN THE CASE.
BRING THE REST OF THE PANEL
IN, YES OR NO.
WHETHER JAMES COMEY USED A
STILL THE SAME VIOLATION.
>> IT IS.
HE WAS ACTING IN THE SCOPE
IT IS GOVERNMENT PROPERTY.
IT'S NOT HIS.
HE IS NOT ALLOWED TO TAKE IT
WITH HIM.
AND THERE ARE PRETTY
MEMOS ARE CLASSIFIED
MATERIALS.
WHICH MEANS THAT COMEY
TAKING THEM HOME IS A CRIME
JUST LIKE HILLARY CLINTON
COMMITTED CRIMES IN MY
JUDGMENT BY HAVING 110
CLASSIFIED EMAILS ON HER
HOME PERSONAL UNAUTHORIZED
UNSECURED SERVER.
>> David: LET'S BRING IN OUR
PANEL IN FULL VIEW LARRY
GOOD TO SEE YOU, MARK GOOD
TALKED ABOUT THAT ASPECT IS
THERE.
BUT, THE REPUBLICANS HAVE TO
POLITICAL ANALYST.
OR DO YOU SEE THE TYPICAL
WASHINGTON COMMISSION THAT
POSTURES AS THEY GO THROUGH
THEIR TIME?
>> I THINK DAVID, AT THIS
POINT, THERE HAS BEEN SO
THAT MOST REPUBLICANS RIGHT
NOW ARE CONTENT LET THE
THING PLAY OUT.
ALL OF THESE PROBLEMS
REGARDING THE BIAS, PEOPLE
INVOLVED IN THE
INVESTIGATION, THIS PHONY
DOSSIER THAT GREGG WAS
TALKING ABOUT.
BELIEVE IT DEMOCRATS ALREADY
WANT HIM IMPEACHED.
INDEPENDENCE ARE IN THE
MIDDLE.
YOU ARE NOT GOING TO FIND
TWO THIRDS SENATORS WILLING
TO THROW DONALD TRUMP OUT OF
THE OFFICE IN THE UNLIKELY
EVENT THAT THE DEMOCRATS
TAKE OVER THE HOUSE AND
IMPEACH HIM.
LET IT GO.
HE WILL BE OVERWHELMINGLY
REENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION
AGENCY ELECTED.
THAT'S HOW MOST REPUBLICANS
ARE PLAYING THIS RIGHT NOW.
THINK IT'S A PERFECTLY VALID
AND SENSIBLE WAY OF PLAYING
IT LET IT PLAY OUT.
>> David: LET'S TAKE IT
RIGHT INSIDE THE WHITE HOUSE
OR FORMNER THIS CASE.
AEST HOUGH TOPICS.
LOOKING AT THE POINT OF VIEW
YOU HAVE BEEN THERE, HOW DO
YOU TAKE THIS IF YOU ARE THE
ADMINISTRATION.
HOW DO YOU APPROACH THIS?
LET IT PLAY OUT AS LARRY
SAID?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THE WHITE HOUSE CONTINUES TO
COOPERATE FULLY WITH THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL THROUGH ALL
TO THIS BEING DONE IN AN
EXAT THE DICIOUSZ FASHION.
ONE OF THE KEY THINGS THAT
WE HAVE ALSO FOUND OUT HERE
JUST RECENTLY AND SOME VERY
GOOD REPORTING BY "THE
WASHINGTON POST" THAT THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION NEW
YEAR'S AGO ABOUT THE WARNING
SIGNS THAT WERE DEVELOPING
OF WHAT RUSSIA WAS PLANNING
TO DO HOW THEY WERE PLANNING
TO ATTACK ELECTIONS
INTEGRITY WITH CYBER
WARFARE.
AND THEY DID NOTHING ABOUT
IT.
SO, HERE'S ONCE AGAIN
ANOTHER CASE WHERE THE
FECKLESS LEADERSHIP OF THE
FORMER ADMINISTRATION LED TO
THE PROBLEMS THAT DONALD
TRUMP IS HAVING TO CLEAN UP
AS PRESIDENT, WEATHER IT'S
FUNDING HE SEE COCAINE AND
TURNING A BLIND EYE TO THAT
DEMOCRATS DON'T HAVE A
MESSAGE.
A WITCH-HUNT TO COVER
PRESIDENT OBAMA'S FAILURES.
LEGAL ASPECTS OF THIS AND
MARC JUST MENTIONED THE
EXTENSION OF THIS IF THEY
FIND OUT THERE WAS UNDUE
INFLUENCE EXERTED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION OR WITH SOME
30 AGENCIES AS BEING
REPORTED BY POLITICO OF ALL
THINGS, INVOLVED IN THIS
OPERATION PROJECT CASSANDRA,
ARE THESE ADJUNCT TO THIS
WHICH MUELLER USED TO BE THE
DIRECTOR.
THIS REQUIRES A SECOND
SPECIAL COUNSELOR.
IF IT TURNS OUT THAT PEOPLE
FOR POLITICAL REASONS SENIOR
MANAGEMENT AND THE FBI TO
WAS ABSOLVED, AND WENT AFTER
DONALD TRUMP TARGETING HIM
AS THE SO-CALLED INSURANCE
POLICY LAW FIRMING A
FRAUDULENT INVESTIGATION
AGAINST HIM, ALL OF THAT
WOULD CONSTITUTE OBSTRUCTION
OF JUSTICE SEVERAL PEOPLE.
DON'T COUNT ON JEFF SESSIONS
>> BACK TO LARRY ELDER BEING
ON THE POLITICS OF THIS.
ON THE EXPANSION OF THE
INVESTIGATION.
ISSUE.
AND BRING OUT THE BAD ACTORS
AND CHARGE THEM.
MY FRIEND, AGAIN, I AM
SKEPTICAL OF THE ABILITY OF
WASHINGTON TO FOCUS GIVEN
THE DEEP STATE EXISTENCE OF
MANY IN THE TOP ECHELON AND
THIS IS NOT ABOUT THE LINE
AGENT.
THIS IS SUITS VS. BOOTS.
AND THE SUITS AND THE
POLITICALS THAT HAVE BEEN
MADE PERMANENT, I THINK
THAT'S WHERE A LOT OF THIS
PROBLEM LIES.
>> WELL, THIS IS ALL ABOUT
THE ALLEGATION THAT TRUMP IS
IN BED WITH PUTIN.
THE PERSON THAT OUGHT TO
BE -- WE OUGHT TON LOOKING
AT IN TERMS OF BEING IN BED
WITH PUTIN WAS BARACK OBAMA.
ONE OF PRESIDENT OBAMA'S
FIRST ACTS AS PRESIDENT WAS
TO DITCH THE DEAL THAT
GEORGE W. BUSH HAD
NEGOTIATED FOR A DEFENSE OF
POLAND AND THE CZECH
REPUBLIC BECAUSE HE WANTED
TO CURRY FAVOR WITH THE
RUSSIANS AND DO THE IRAN
DEAL.
IT WAS OBAMA ON HOT MIKE
TOLD MEDVEDEV AFTER THE
ELECTION I WILL HAVE MORE
FLEXIBILITY.
IT WAS OBAMA WHO SLAMMED
MITT ROMNEY SUGGESTING
IF ANYBODY WANTS TO TALK
ABOUT WHO WAS COZYING UP
WITH RUSSIA AND PUTIN, WE
OUGHT TO BE TALKING ABOUT
OBAMA.
NOT TRUMP.
TERRIFIED DAVID ALL RIGHT.
MARC.
WE CAN'T GO BACK IN TIME.
FORTUNATELY WE CAN LOOK AT
IT WE CAN LOOK AT ACTIONS
TAKEN BY THE PREVIOUS
YOU HAVE GOT TO MOVE THE
BALL FORWARD ON THIS.
AND DOES EXAMINING THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION'S ACTIONS
BRING US ANY CLOSER TO
EXPOSING WHAT'S GOING ON
INSIDE THE DEEP STATE WITHIN
THE LIBERAL QUARTERS OR THE
WASHINGTON QUARTERS OR THE
BUREAUCRATIC QUARTERS?
>> OBVIOUSLY, IF YOU ARE
GOING TO INFLUENCE ELECTIONS
OR COME UP WITH INSURANCE
POLICIES, THAT NEEDS TO BE
LOOKED AT.
BECAUSE THERE COULD BE AND I
WILL TRUST GREGG ON THAT IF
THERE IS POTENTIAL
CRIMINALITY THERE.
MEAN WHILE THE PRESIDENT,
THE VICE PRESIDENT THE
ENTIRE WHITE HOUSE ARE
FOCUSED ON DOING THE JOB OF
THE ENTIRE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THEY GOT TAX CUTS DONE.
NEXT COUPLE MONTHS, NEXT ON
TO IMMIGRATION,
INFRASTRUCTURE, AND POSSIBLY
EVEN ENTITLEMENT REFORM.
THE PRESIDENT IS BARELY
GETTING STARTED OF RIGHT
NOW.
THEY WILL KEEP FOCUSED ON
CRAGHTS TO THOSE WHO DO IT
BEST.